[Applaudissements]
que lui répondez vous la république pour
les bons mots ne font pas un projet
politique
donc c'est bien il fait un effet de
tribune il fait un effet de style mais
quid du projet politique écouter le
parti socialiste est en train de vivre
un ouvrage j'ai bien écouté ce kadio
didier forillère et sur la révision
constitutionnelle
je vous engage à relire toutes les
contributions de tous les congrès du
parti socialiste depuis 30 ans quels que
soient les sensibilités
ils étaient tous favorables à la baisse
du nombre de parlementaires ils étaient
tous favorables à l'introduction d'une
dose de proportionnelle pour mieux
meilleure représentativité des minorités
donc ils ont depuis 30 ans écrit dans
tous leurs textes que la réforme que
nous sommes en train de proposer était
la bonne et là parce que c'est nous qui
la propose on on a compris hier qu'il ne
la veut traitement qu'il a fait le choix
lui quand un mot ce qu'il a fait le
choix en partie des taux à gauche tout
dans l'opposition et le choix de son
parti plutôt que de son pays et là c'est
une faute voilà pour vous après les
français apprécieront c'est pas à moi
d'apprécier mais je crois que au regard
de l'impérieuse nécessité des temps que
nous vivons et de la situation que
traverse notre pays économique politique
social il est temps de choisir son pays
et de préférer son pays à son parti